we're standing in front of the building
that houses the Commission on
Presidential Debates back in two
thousand they said hey you got to be at
fifteen percent in five national polls
that we pick Gary Johnson bill well they
did not cut it with the American public
there at eight point six eight point
four percent according Real Clear
Politics why should they be in the polls
were not correct they didn't ask about
him on the first question I read all the
methodologies and his name was buried
down and down deep into the questions
and also the CN n 0 RC poll that came
out if you look at every single page on
from 18 to 34 year olds it was na so
they didn't even get enough statistical
data to even represent it certain polls
have underrepresented 35 and under other
polls have ended have underrepresented
independence independence make a path of
the voting population in the united
states and some polls only hold
democrats and republicans and they only
included about fifteen percent
representation from from independence
there's a ground swell of opinion in
this country that we need multi-party
politics or third party politics and it
just so happens that you know history is
set the table with johnson weld it's
such a strong ticket that if these guys
can't beat the damn breakers to get us
you know to multi-party politics
nobody's going to but I got to tell you
it's the extremists on both sides that
are ruining America so you see Gary
Johnson and bill weld a centrist you
know because normally the knock-on
libertarians is that there are these
crazy people out there on the horizon
talking about a you know selling crack
cocaine and grammar school I just i I
don't I see their side of it but I'm not
going to agree with any candidate 100%
the only person could agree with a
hundred percent of the time is myself so
barring that i align myself to johnson
weld more than any other i don't agree
with everything gary johnson has to say
right now he is the only one in the
middle he's the only libertarian who has
any chance of getting on the national
stage and saying like hey we can agree
to disagree but the number one priority
in America has to be Liberty what do you
like most about Gary Johnson that he's
speaking honestly about the issues i'm
concerned
about which are the tax code and how
complicated it's become and Social
Security which needs to be reformed I
believe he's the best choice for our
country and I want a smaller government
I hopefully want to get some of the
troops home stop all the stupid Wars you
said earlier you drove all the way from
Boston that is some kind of commitment
would you do that for any other
presidential candidate absolutely not I
am outraged at the thought of a Clinton
or a trump presidency I think it's
embarrassing I think it's embarrassing
for America that we are going to have
people that are known crooks and liars
speaking for us and being in basically
being our American icon well we're here
protesting the decision not to let Gary
debate and obviously we all want Gary on
that stage with the other two candidates
and we wouldn't mind seeing Jill up
there too since views align with mine
very well any small L libertarian
republican and I think that that's a
huge part of the party would be happy to
support him but I also think that we're
teaching our kids to vote for bad people
we're telling our children the two-party
system has nominated these two
candidates and they're your only choice
and everyone who supports one of those
two candidates I hear them saying yeah I
hate my candidate but they're less of a
liar than the other candidate and less
of a liar is not a good reason to vote
for someone he's now on all 50 ballots
plus the District of Columbia and I
think it's imperative for the American
people to understand truly what their
choices and they do have an alternative
choice to Trump and Hillary are you a
traditionally are you a Republican and
Democrat libertarian where do you fall
I've always been a Democrat and always
voted that way what do you think
explains his immense popularity among
younger people well of course
libertarians were a little worried with
the Bernie phenomenon that the
millennium see lights Ron Paul just for
an eight years ago or something going
socialist but you know their concern
about Hillary I think is making them
look at Gary or jill stein and seeing
his liberal positions and a lot of
social issues whether it's the drug war
or intervention overseas regime change
or privacy you know the surveillance
state over criminal
zation a host of issues where governor
johnson is better than Hillary on but
I've never done this we're not activists
I've never even put a bumper sticker on
my car I've never donated to a campaign